let's say you want to figure out what 5
600 divided by 8 is now you might be
tempted to do some type of long division
8 into 5
600 and you could do it this way and
you're using paper but what i want to
show you is that you could maybe do this
in your head or maybe even just use less
paper to do it and the key realization
here is like look if you got these two
zeros here this is really the same thing
as
56
times 100
divided by 8. 56 times 100 is 5
600. you got the two zeros here you got
the two zeros here let me make it very
clear two zeros here you got the two
zeros here in fact sometimes people will
call this number 5600 56 hundreds so
5600
is the same thing as 56 times 100 and
when you write it this way then you
might say hey well instead of doing 56
times 100 divided by 8 i can switch the
order this is going to be the same thing
this is going to be the same thing as
this is going to be the same thing as 56
56 divided by 8
divided by 8
divided by 8 times 100
times
100
times 100. now why did i do this
well it's pretty straightforward if you
remember your multiplication tables what
56 divided by 8 is 8 times 7 is 56
so this right over here is going to be 7
and so then you're just left with
figuring out what 7 times 100 is
7 times one hundred well that's going to
be seven hundreds or
seven
seven hundreds is just seven hundred
seven
hundred
and you're done
let's do more of these where we might be
tempted to do some type of long division
but if we really think about ways to
break up the numbers we might be able to
do it with less paper or possibly even
in our heads
so let's say that you had the number
let's say you had the number 800 i'm
just in a different color
let's say you had the number
846
846 and you want to divide that by 2.
well the realization here or what you
might think about is let's break this
number up let's break up this 846
846
is the same thing this is going to be
actually let me do it this way
846 is the same thing as
this is the same thing as 800
800 plus 40
plus
40
plus 6
plus
6
and so 846 the same thing as 800 plus 40
plus 6 and so we can just divide that by
2. we can just divide that by 2
divided
by two so notice didn't do anything too
fancy here this is just the same thing
as this over here and i just broke it up
you have eight hundreds four tens which
is forty and six and you can divide that
by two well how does that help us
well now we can divide each of these
separately by two one way to think about
it is we can we can distribute the divi
the division by two where you might be
familiar with using the distributive
property and multiplication but you
could also do it with division so this
thing right over here is going to be the
same thing this is going to be equal to
800 divided by 2
800
divided by 2
divided by 2 plus 40 divided by 2
plus 40 divided by 2
and i'm going to add parentheses in a
second to make it a little bit clearer
plus 6 divided by 2 plus
plus 6 divided by 2.
so plus 6 divided by 2
divided
plus 6 divided by
2. so once again
you have
800 divided let me do that same you have
800 divided by 2 that's that right over
there
plus
40
divided by 2 40 divided by 2 plus 6
divided by 2
plus
6 divided by 2. so we distributed the
division by two well eight hundred
divided by two you should do in your
head it's this is eight hundreds divide
that by two you're gonna get four
hundreds
four hundred four tens divided by two is
going to be two tens
is going to be two tens or twenty
so eight to eight hundreds divided by
two is four hundreds four tens divided
by two is two tens and then six divided
by two is three
so you are left with four hundred plus
20 plus 3 which of course is equal to
400
and
423
now i used a lot of my screen here to
work this out for you so that you really
digest what's going on here but once you
get good at it you could say okay look 8
divided by 2 is 800 divided by 2 is 4
hundreds actually i can do it right over
here 800 divided by 2 is 4 hundreds 4
tens divided by two is two tens and six
ones divided by two is three ones so you
could say hey look if i just divide each
of these numbers by two i get four
hundred and twenty three but this is
what you were really doing you were
separating it out by place value you
were you were dividing each of those
places in the hundreds the tens and the
ones by the two by two and then you got
423 and by the way that's exactly what
you would do if you actually did it
through long division you're actually
just dividing the two into each of the
places let's do one more just to really
make sure that we we are fully enjoying
this so let's say let's say that i have
900
and
900
963
963 and i want to divide that by
and divide that by 9.
well over here you might make the
realization well i can see parts of this
that i know how to divide by 9.
so i could say this is the same thing as
900 and i'm breaking out the 900 because
i know how to divide 900 divided by 9.
so that's 900 and then i know what i
know that 63 is a multiple of 9. so why
don't i break out 63 separately i don't
even have to break out the tens and the
ones separately so i can say this is the
same thing as 900 plus 63 and all of
that
divided by
divided by 9. well this is going to be
the same thing as 900 divided by 9.
let me do that in the brown color
900
divided by
9
plus 63 divided by 9 plus
63 divided by 9. i just distributed the
division by 9. so let me put some
parentheses around this and what is this
going to be equal to well 900 divided by
9 is 100
this is going to be
100 and 63 divided by 9 is 7
is 7. so this is going to be 100 plus 7
or
100
100 and
107. and so once again i wrote it all
out like this but once you get some
practice you'll say hey look 9 goes into
900
100 times 9 goes into 63 seven times so
9 goes into 963 107 times hopefully you
found that fun and this is this is this
is useful stuff because one of the most
important things you're going to have to
find is all the time you're going to
find these numbers while you're doing
you know your your finances or you're
trying to calculate the check at a
restaurant and you're going to find it
really valuable to be able to do this
type of division and with some practice
even without paper